hey chris d'elia here um I know a lot of
you guys make C of my videos online and
you know I'm a comedian and I put up the
videos to make you laugh but uh you know
I've been on the road and it's kind of
lonely on the road here I'm staying with
a friend of mine and I just kind of
wanted to make a video you know also to
show you that people who have pain in
their lives to help them kind of get
through it so here's a video for you if
you're having trouble in one way or
another I want you to afford this link
to you or anybody you know if you if
you're having trouble worked on a little
song here Amazing Grace how sweet the
sound that saved a wretch like me I once
was lost but now AM found was blind but
now I see twas grace that taught my hey
men hey what are you doing I'm making a
video from for like the internet I asked
you to please ask me if you wanted to
use my camera I'm sorry it's [ __ ]
3:30 in the morning man yeah I can't
sleep because it's jet lag and I'm
trying I'm sorry I won't do it it's I
mean it's so loud you're doing it so
loud yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry okay
okay I won't do it I'm sorry backup
night
Amazing Grace how sweet the sound that
saved a wretch like me I once was lost
I'm not joking I was quieter close the
door you see if the doors closed
the walls are thin I am sorry I won't do
it anymore I just you know it's like I
feel it now I want to do it now just
I've got an interview tomorrow like just
don't do it please can you just do it to
me I'll do it tomorrow I'm sorry
I'll do tomorrow I'm sorry I please
don't you know don't do it at all Waldo
tomorrow I just say it's important I'll
do it tomorrow so while you're at work
yeah I'll do it tomorrow
before my shop yeah oh oh what I said
all right don't do it you know I just
let me use no don't I'm so Sid stop okay
Otto's market stop okay I'm sorry
just let me use come on [ __ ] pass give
me my camera okay good night I'll do it
tomorrow I want you out by tomorrow okay
yeah okay